yeah you're on the butt side of it
you're behind the the weight line
yeah
can you see that okay okay so we're
here i'm going to do my market push okay
and it's very common you're you're
thinking married with gravity okay so
you're like if my center goes down then
the joe is heavy you see that
but my weight is actually parallel to
the chill
not over the gym you see that
when you do that so when i say you're on
your butt side you're over here
you want to get your weight
on this line here
got it
[Music]
okay different you see
here like that
okay
okay so at some point my partner and i
whatever you're gonna you're gonna find
that you you got the arms okay and what
we're going to do is just go into that
position
okay
so it could be she starts punching at me
right we'll eventually get the arms and
we're going to go right into that it
could bend we were hand puffy she
started scrapping and we're gonna go
right into that position do you see that
so again we're just gonna start
administratively
uh things start to go south one thing
you want to try for
is tight okay
and then your power line
you activate that rear posterior chain
okay and we're here like this
so
there it is here
down down down communicate with your
partner
right
forward forward forward forward okay and
now we'll just walk her out
and we're done
don't
[Music]
um
okay and i'm keeping that position here
but i'm not on her torso okay in this
position here
all right let's try it
[Music]
okay
and um don't just pay attention okay
uh this is one of the problems with
aikido people
so this is a this is don't change
anything this is good
this is not all right let's see
so
get it
here thumbless and anchor that elbow to
your body
and bring your body to it right now your
arm wrestling baby you see that right
meaning you're pulling my arm
do it again
do it again stop go ahead keep it doing
don't let me get away okay all right
what you want to do instead is you hug
your body to my arm
you get you you're attached to my arm so
if my arm moved your body would move
no you're still using your hamstrings
look it's gonna happen every time do it
again
so that that grip is what's checking my
height
so
there i got out
and now i get my mobility done
so when i'm here you're doing this
and i'm doing this
pull your arm up
pull it wherever you want walk around
run around
so it's two ways of thinking about it
there's the fear way
trying to overpower someone trying to
make their arm come to you
and then the other way is keep yourself
on their arm
you see that so you keep doing this
which if i'm way stronger than you i
could probably do it okay but when
fights move take a step
and now i don't have the same leverage
right here you see just with that one
step you're gonna drop your elbow this
way and pull your arm jersey
okay
so
even if i start out strong
administratively fight smooth and you
lose your leverage and they gain their
leverage so it's never a good tackler
and also you're burning energy
so
not a fear response here
uh
you stick to this thing you're sticking
to this thing you see and i'm just
holding myself and i'm sticking to that
different
okay
try
uh so when we so it's important you
don't slam people so when we have both
arms
i'm not trying to take her down
and slam her face down
and also towards that same man
i have to be in control of the descent
which by extension means that i i can
hold her up do you see that so
you want to think incrementally
not face down but line of gravity
outside her base of support and knees
down
do you got that so we would go
oh
and you aim for those knees do you see
how we did that okay
so instead of like cool and we shove her
there so you have to go because we have
control right so here we're here like
this and you do whatever you want do
whatever you want
run around use your whole legs we say do
we can move and we're just going to stay
here and we'll just burn her out
okay so we don't have to be afraid and
slammer right away we already have
control so pay attention we go down and
get her knees to go like that you see
and now if she tries to fall forward
we have her she can't fall forward you
see that and so we're lowering her
lowering her trying to fall forward
you think she can't fall forward we're
lowering lowering lowering lowering okay
um so we have a couple choices here
we can pass this kind of like katakatama
if we feel there's an opening
so
we're just going to come up
control the echo
and thread the knee other way
this way
and then we have this
which we did the other day okay be in
the arm off the respiratory system
ground the upward knee so your weight is
on the output here okay
if there's a third person
then come
cross the ankles
come up okay and nobody's on her
respiratory system
okay so talk
louder
abcd okay so keep singing h.a
that's different okay
so we're not on her respiratory system
all right
and then you can coordinate your
handcuffing here so we'll have you
handcuff you would pull out your cuffs
and i would bring it back
we do one and keep this elbow in and
beat
on the hip or off the body all the time
so let's do the lowering
incrementally
and be cognizant that you can support
that weight so they don't slam their
head face okay because you have both
hands all right go let's do another
basic is one person again never never do
this one person
your greatest advantage is your numbers
you always have your numbers if you
don't have your numbers either don't
engage you just shoot shoot the
until the numbers get there okay
uh that's different from them attacking
me okay if they're attacking me it's
forced upon me that's a different
situation you might have to go one
one-on-one okay
um
here we're just gonna work on this basic
so i'm gonna bring this arm behind her
and change hand positions over here okay
so i'm going to demonstrate it
i was here
i'm going to pass it
and now i'm in the back okay
so
i'm going to show some different angles
here
this part i keep control
see this this is the part that gives me
the control it's not so much okay this
part is the one when she starts moving
around if i can keep that elbow i have
way more control so i'm just holding
here she's our friend around see i don't
know
okay so emphasize
this hand
so as i pass it around i still have that
hand
then i come up duplicate that control
and then find the wrist
i'll do it in this angle
and here
i still have the hand on the elbow
duplicate that control
and then find the wrist and now change
to the back okay
all right let's work that please so at
some point in this scuffle or whatever
you ended up here
okay
and there's a lot of energy he doesn't
want to go he's making his base go
forward and we're not strong enough to
get it
this is where he's going he
has resistance going that way so you
tell your partner to the rear and go and
your hair like this now okay and you can
do the same
uh drop you can come around bouncing
you're gonna do the same drop but you
gotta watch the back of the head okay so
you want him to go down onto his butt
again when we're here uh we can just
exhaust him we don't have to panic okay
so do whatever you want it's fine it's
fine it's fine okay and then his butt so
maybe even his knees in this case
because he's so far back you see
and then to his butt
boom
here and again try to lay down
you see he can't hit his head okay
um from here you can go to your seated
cuffing
this way
okay
you're in this position
um so you we did this technique last
time you're gonna hand me that elbow
okay keep that wrist
and then you would use your hand to get
your handcuffs
and so again we're here so move around
andrew
hank
we're here like this okay
and we just handcuffed
so just like going forward it goes knees
then shoulder
which means you have to actually aim for
that with your force vectors
and then two you have to have some
capacity
to
slow hold so he does not hit his head
because we have both arms okay
and then lastly
uh be patient because
he's not going anywhere because i'm
stuck to his arms okay got it so
one of the other benefits from this is
facing the front
we got here
is since there's two officers here
uh we don't have to worry about what's
on our waist because he has the other
arm and i have this arm so for example
let's say i'm one guy here and i'm
trying to do this move right
and he tries to go up
and i do my judicial
now my taser and what have you is on
this side i'm exposed to it okay
so that's another advantage of two
people and what i want you to understand
from that is
you can be calm take your time and let
him exhaust himself
and then do this incrementally move down
okay
um
we'll have you guys be the two officers
and we will be the backup officers
because we're wearing shoes and i don't
want you to get hurt okay so you guys
will do that maneuver
you got the arm somehow
he's resisting forwards so we're so what
happens is we want him to go pro
but he he's too strong or whatever or it
could be other environment
so we're going to use the seated
position disadvantage you see that to do
the hand pressure okay we're not going
to take them back onto this supine
position
okay so uh what i have had happen
is okay we get the initial uh yin
opening
go and then he regains his posture here
you think okay and he's really really
strong he's got a good stroller core
this is where that exhaustion technique
comes in you're fine okay you can even
kind of fake them out by by the way that
you would do somebody who's down and
i'll mount you
you see
because i want about shane to tell me
you guys just hang there she's down and
i i want to tire her okay so uh you're
going to push me up you see and i'll
i'll have her lift just enough and then
then i'll swim in
and she'll go whereas if i just do my
technique though
she's never going to get me go ahead try
your hardest
she's never going to get me so she'll
stop wasting energy then do you see but
i want her to waste energy
so same thing here you kind of fake
faith so he keeps struggling and keeps
wet you know wasting energy without you
compromising your position so just very
minor stuff okay
and then uh
when you decide it's time to go
you guys are gonna give us
this back
here
you see that
and you're going to put your
foot trap right here all right make sure
you don't give them the inside of your
knee so my knees on the outside and now
you guys will do
the descent down go now
there you go nice okay
and you would go into it so we'll do it
again
okay so you guys got positioned
we're all solid we're not going to
document him and shut him down and all
this kind of stuff you're good he goes
right we're ready we're ready he's doing
this
give us get your foot in there okay here
we go go go go go
good
okay and then you would do that the
handcuff
okay
all right let's try it
you guys drop me
right forward
there you go see how it's clear right
and i'm going to go like this i'm going
to regain my base you see
okay so you keep doing that and now
you're looking so you got to get behind
me you got to get ready got to get ready
i'm going to keep doing it i'm going to
keep doing it
and say oh head butts you got to look
out okay you got to pay attention keep
going get it to go so i think you i
think taylor's like f you guys
he's got the got this one leg so as i
pick it up that's when you take me down
taylor
okay
so we'll say scrolls you're doing that
and uh
she goes
right and i'm looking for her you see
how we got right in there you see how i
did that what what's protecting your
face
right look out for this you don't want
her spitting at you so turn your head
away see where i am
and then i'm going to help
with the pelvis drop
okay it's very dynamic when it
starts going more towards the field